jedes mal wenn eine ärztin oder arzt
eine diagnose stellt stehen die für eine
art entscheidungsbaum die patientin
sieht nicht mehr so gut okay das könnte
natürlich einfach altersbedingt sein
dass die patienten aber noch
lichtempfindlich und scharfes sehen
funktioniert nur noch am rande des
blickfeldes in der mitte hingegen wird
es immer schwieriger ob die probleme mit
den augen jetzt einfach nur noch alters
link sind ist gar nicht mehr so leicht
zu beantworten
jetzt kommen auch noch ein paar
chronische krankheiten eine
ernährungsumstellung oder
gewichtsverlust ins spiel und ihr seht
das ist ganz schön kompliziert bei einer
diagnose geht es eben nicht nur um akute
symptome sondern auch um alles drum
herum inklusive der letzten krankheiten
angewohnheiten und der ernährung dieser
prozess nennt sich anamnese das ist ein
echter skills auch der grund warum
greifen zu googeln vielleicht gar nicht
die beste idee ist
ausgebildete medizinerinnen und
mediziner können den kontext von
symptomen verstehen und einschätzen da
gibt es nun leider ein problemen
menschen nach einem fehler und lange
schichten keine zentralen patientenakten
und viel stress machen das ganze nicht
unbedingt leichter deswegen arbeitet ein
forscherteam aus münchen gerade daran
die diagnose von krankheiten mit
künstlicher intelligenz zu unterstützen
aber wie funktioniert so was genau und
wird so etwas vielleicht in zukunft
einmal ärzte ersetzen können um all das
zu beantworten bin ich nach münchen
gefahren und habe mich selber einmal von
dieser ki analysieren lassen
[Musik]
computer vision beschäftigt die computer
science schon seit den 60er jahren und
das ist ein super komplexes thema dinge
wieder zu erkennen ist für uns menschen
total einfach aber einem computer
beizubringen welche visuellen
eigenschaften zum beispiel so ein apfel
hat ist extrem kompliziert
farbliche gestaltung
formen und vieles mehr die dinge um uns
herum haben super viele eigenschaften
und das ganze ist von vielen äußeren
faktoren abhängig falls euch generell
für künstliche intelligenz und auch
maschinen learning interessiert dann
schaut euch am besten diese reichen von
uns an da erklären wir alle basics rund
um das thema die auch für dieses video
hirt relevant sind denn jetzt kommt lodi
ins spiel lotti steht für longitudinal
listen die learning ganz einfach gesagt
ist lodi ein system das mit computer
vision die augen von patientinnen und
patienten auswertet longitudinal
bedeutet hierbei dass das nicht nur
einmal passiert sondern regelmäßig so
kann das system über einen längeren
zeitraum verschiedene stadien an der
krankheit kennen lernen und durch diese
analyse kann das system dann helfen zum
beispiel in amd neo vaskuläre
makuladegeneration zu diagnostizieren
denn das system wurde mit hunderten
verläufen trainiert und weiß ganz genau
wie sich die krankheit entwickeln kann
und die symptome dieser krankheit die
kennt ihr schon aus dem intro von diesem
video hier die makula ist ein ganz
kleiner fleck auf unserer netzhaut hier
kann man am schärfsten sehens mit der
zeit können sich aber ablagerungen auf
ihr festsetzen und im schlimmsten fall
können krankhafte blutgefäße in die
netzhaut einwachsen und zunamen führen
das sorgt dafür dass man in der mitte
des sichtfeldes zunehmend schlechter
sieht farben und kontraste schwächer
werden und strukturen verzerrt wird
betroffene sind meistens schon etwas
älter und unter umständen kann diese
netzhauterkrankung bis zur vollständigen
erblindung führen damit es soweit nicht
kommt muss man die krankheit früher
diagnostizieren optimal also wenn man
ein system hätte dass die anzeichen
dafür automatisch erkennen würde okay
ein system also dass wir nur durch
bilder von meinen augen eine diagnose
vorschlägt es klingt fast zu gut um wahr
zu sein aber kann sowas wirklich
funktionieren um das zu überprüfen wenn
ich jetzt nach münchen fahren und meine
augen von einer ki analysieren lassen
[Musik]
normalerweise findet man eine mio
vaskuläre makuladegeneration indem man
einen termin bei einer expertin oder
einem experten macht und auch lodi
braucht daten von einem speziellen gerät
um mich analysieren zu können deswegen
sind wir in die münchner innenstadt
gefahren und ich habe einen o ct scan
von mir machen lassen bei so einem scan
werden die verschiedenen schichten der
retina aufgenommen das ist so ein
bisschen wie ultraschall mit licht und
es ist komplett harmlos für das auge
aber bevor die ki meine daten bekommen
hat konnte mit der augenarzt vor ort
schon sagen ob ich eine n a die
erkrankung habe oder nicht also genau
das was die ki später machen soll nur
mit einem wichtigen unterschied zu dem
wir gleich kommen werden mit meinen
augen bildern sind wir dann zu fabian
theiß dem leiter vom projekt lodi
gefahren und haben uns mal erklären
lassen wie das ganze eigentlich genau
funktioniert dabei haben wir ihm
übrigens auch fragen von euch aus der
community gestellt die ihr uns über
instagram geschickt hat zum beispiel
diese hier wie und mit welchen daten
wurde der dieb learning algorithmus
gefüttert wir setzen uns mit unseren
kollegen aus der augenklinik zu sammeln
und gesagt geh auf diesem bild erkenne
ich dass der altersbedingte
makuladegeneration hat der einzige
großen vier typen nie wer in dieser
datenbank beim aufnehmen und jetzt
können wir einen algorithmus machenden
neuronales netz also ein machine
learning methode oder wie man heutzutage
oft eine künstliche intelligenz sind
aber nichts anderes ist als eine
funktion die so ein 3d volumen von dem
augen und darauf abbildet auf hey da hat
diese amd oder hat es nicht jetzt geh
mal über die epochen wie diese
algorithmen trainiert wieder lernen und
lehren du siehst ja langsam diese farben
hiernach nach gruppen cluster der trüben
ist der gesunde da drüben ist er mit der
schwersten rezessionen dazwischen ist er
mit mittlere und noch mal dazwischen den
müde
wir sehen auch da diese übergänge und
kann sich frage stellen hätte die
patientin die nadeln ranzen haben die
vielleicht schon so eine prädisposition
zu diesem ding mit den aufnahmen meiner
augen kann ich also den krankheits grad
sortieren das heißt das system kann
erkennen ob ich krank bin und wenn ja in
welchem stadium sich die krankheit
gerade befinde was ich aber besonders
cool finde wenn ich tatsächlich an der
em die krankheit leiden würde könnte man
auch mehrere bilder über einen längeren
zeitraum an lodi geben und durch die
informationen in einer so genannten
zeitreihe kann man dann sehen wie sich
die krankheit wie möglich entwickeln
wird oder auch auf eine therapie
anschlägt und so kann man eine
korrelation von kausalität
unterschreiben das wird normalerweise
nur in klinischen studien gemacht und
wenn ihr darüber noch mehr erfahren
wollt dann solltet ihr euch unbedingt
dieses video hier von uns ansehen aber
ich weiß was ihr euch jetzt fragt
versteht die ki also klo die wirklich
was sie da tut solche systeme werden ja
schnell zu einer sogenannten black box
in die man nicht hineinsehen kann und wo
man nicht weiß welche entscheidungen
dort getroffen werden aber fabian hat
mir versichert dass man sich bei lo die
jeden einzelnen punkt im neuronalen
netzwerk natürlich anonymisiert angucken
und schauen kann wie das system die
entscheidungen getroffen hat so kann man
dann feststellen dass lodi wirklich nach
anzeichen für die krankheit und nicht
nach korrelierenden variablen sucht und
um das mal in action zu sehen haben wir
lodi dann endlich mit bildern von meinen
augen gefüttert und das ganze dann live
analysieren lassen und zwar von hanna ja
ich bin hanna spitze ich arbeite hier am
helmholtz zentrum in münchen als postdoc
in der machine learning gruppe ich habe
einen ots gern mit meinen beiden augen
machen lassen die daten habe ich jetzt
gerade mitgebracht und wir wollen die
jetzt in euer die learning netzwerk
herein füttern und wollen mal gucken was
dabei rauskommt funktioniert das so und
kann ich mir das vorstellen genau also
das können wir so machen ich kann die
daten jetzt hier auf meinem computer
kopieren dann muss ich die nur natürlich
erst mal einlesen und dann kann ich die
direkt in das neuronale netzwerk reintun
als eingabedaten und dann würden wir
gucken was da rauskommt und dann laden
wir das jetzt einfach mal ich leide
jetzt hier ds bild von seinem linken
auge und ja das segment ihren wir jetzt
und visualisieren das direkt malen hier
unten kannst dann sehen das ist dein
deine retina diese dieses wo es hier
untergeht das ist die makula der ort des
schärfsten sehens und hier das ist was
unser algorithmus dazu sagt können wir
da sehen es sieht eigentlich super aus
wir haben hier in grün die büros sowie
retina das ist die
sehzellen in deinem auge also die
schicht die tatsächlich dass das sehen
macht für die ganzen photorezeptoren
drin sind die ganze neuronen das ist
super da gibt es keine flüssigkeit
einschlüsse die würden wir hier sonst in
so einem leichten blau sehen und ja und
hier in blau das ist der der glaskörper
das ist auch gut so braucht man auch
genau hanna hat das so gut programmiert
dass das wirklich ein selbst erklären
das programm ist also eigentlich hätte
ich sie fast gar nicht gebraucht und ich
habe auch schon erwähnt dass mir der
arzt in der augenklinik auch relativ
schnell sagen konnte dass mit meinen
augen eigentlich alles in ordnung ist
aber genau da ist der unterschied wenn
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich von
den bildern von o ct scan nichts erkannt
habe da habe ich nichts drin sehen
können die analyse durch lobby wiederum
konnte ich direkt verstehen das heißt
die kg produziert ergebnisse die selbst
für mich als laien verständlich sind
deswegen mal ganz blöd gefragt werden so
nicht medizinerinnen und mediziner
irgendwann überflüssig es gibt viele
teile in der medizin und in starken
entdeckt haben wird da haben viele
mediziner angst dass dann plötzlich
übergangen werden oder das war es ja
aber ich gehe zum beispiel für eine
erfindung vor vielleicht 200 jahren wo
auch ganz schön angst herrscht ob diese
erfindung dass die den beruf des
mediziners
abschaffen würde sollte er finde das
fieberthermometer
ich habe natürlich gibt es immer noch
mediziner es gibt nur keine mediziner
die keine fieberthermometer wir benutzen
ganz wichtig der algorithmus trifft bei
lo die keine medizinischen
entscheidungen er berät die mediziner
und selbst das nicht wirklich das ging
jetzt nach einem beratungsgespräch
effektive quasi nur eine anzeige gemacht
die der mediziner dann liegst und
trotzdem müssen wir natürlich aufpassen
denn medizinerinnen und mediziner
vertrauen der maschine ergo gibt es eine
große verantwortung bei der entwicklung
solcher programme
aber was das fieberthermometer
eigentlich ganz gut zeigt ist schon
jetzt werden mediziner von total viel
technik unterstützt machine learning ist
eben noch ein weiteres hilfreiches
werkzeug und vielleicht wird es bald
noch viel mehr genutzt denn so ein
system wie lodi kann theoretisch nicht
nur augenkrankheiten erkennen unsere
augen sagen viel mehr über uns aus als
wir glauben nicht nur müdigkeit
fahrtüchtigkeit oder auch das geschlecht
kann man an den augen erkennen sondern
auch krankheiten wie diabetes in frühen
stadien kann man diabetes sonst nur mit
einem bluttest feststellen aber der
zustand der prädiabetes lässt sich auch
über die augen auslesen und vielleicht
kann man in zukunft auch genetische
informationen in so einem system speisen
das lässt sich dann mit spannenden
fragestellungen kombinieren wie ist eine
krankheit vielleicht genetisch bedingt
auch hier könnten wir wieder mehr
zusammenhänge herstellen als je zuvor
und so unseren körper besser verstehen
und mit der zeit wird so ein neuronales
netzwerk nicht nur schlauer sondern
vielleicht auch einfacher zu bedienen
vielleicht mache ich irgendwann einfach
mit meinem smartphone ein bild von
meinen augen und sinne das dann an einem
system wie lodi und dafür gab es auch
handykamera aufsätze und so ein bisschen
die idee mal sagen wir du bist in afrika
oder vielleicht auch nur im bayerischen
wald irgendwo ja nicht an deinen augen
chefarzt hin wie kannst du vielleicht
schnellen diagnosen machen und manchmal
muss es vielleicht diesmal gut sein da
wirst du andere krankheiten ist gut was
zu machen ist ich glaube die idee sagen
die leute die patienten mehr zu nebeln
selber dann auch was zu machen oder
zumindest halt nicht immer den experten
diesen ganz trocken experten ja
vielleicht nur ein paar leute zugleich
behandeln kann und diese langjährige
hintergrund 1900 das irgendwie so zu
abstrahieren das halte ich für extrem
attraktiv dieses demokratisieren von
expertenwissen das ist schon was diese
mine ist eine idee von open source
bewegen und dabei seinen prinzipien
unseren algorithmen kann man das machen
ok es braucht also bestimmte aufsätze
für handy kameras aber die frage ist ja
auch wie wir so etwas in den klinischen
alltag integrieren könnten weil da gibt
es oft einen gewissen gap zwischen der
grundlagenforschung und dem
medizinischen alltag dafür gibt es
natürlich verschiedene gründe aber einer
dürfte keinen überraschen es ist eine
kliniken tatsächlich so das hat die
dinge oft in so verschiedenen silos
rumliegen ich als patient ich möchte
eigentlich wirklich wissen wo meine
daten wenn ich jetzt in schweden während
in dänemark beginnt ist bei uns nicht
mein sohnemann hat sich letztens in
allem relativ stimme gebrochen und ich
wollte danach das bild mitnehmen was ist
die aussage waren unsere cd brenner ist
gerade kaputt ich kannst du nicht
mitgeben hindernis nummer eins ist also
erstmal die zu langsame digitalisierung
in deutschland
dann muss man das ganze natürlich auch
irgendwie benutzerfreundlich machen also
eine app mit einem schönen interface auf
dem smartphone und natürlich braucht man
die richtige kamera also ja da muss noch
eine menge passieren aber das soll jetzt
gar nicht so pessimistisch klingen was
wir uns da anschauen durften war super
interessant und macht mir ehrlich gesagt
unglaublich viel hoffnung so stelle ich
mir eine zukunft vor in der ärzten und
ärzte entlastet und unterstützt werden
und so weniger fehler machen auf diese
weise könnten behandlungen günstiger
besser verfügbar und demokratischer
werden das war wirklich ein super
spannendes thema vielen dank noch mal an
alle vor ort in münchen die uns bei
diesem dreh unterstützt haben falls ihr
noch fragen habt könnt ihr die gerne
unten in den kommentaren stellen und wir
leiten dann eure fragen an die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
von logi weiter und posten euch hier in
den kommentaren ihre antworten ihr könnt
also sehr gerne sehr spezifische fragen
stellen wenn ihr wollt wir haben extrem
viel über dieses spannende projekt
gelernt deswegen an dieser stelle vielen
dank an das bundesministerium für
bildung und forschung die so eine
wichtige entwicklung fördern und mich
auch bei diesem video hier unterstützt
haben und auch vielen dank an den
projektträger jülich und an euch vielen
dank fürs zuschauen und wie immer bleibt
neugierig bis zum nächsten mal patrick